[Music]
one set to determine the greatest Mortal
Kombat player on this planet still it'll
pop up between the forward to it's
another massive comeback for Sonic 1 set
a peace between the two one game between
the two this is the Grand Finals of
final combat everybody ninja killer's
journey as a player is very relatable a
perfect underdog story he has a great
chance at being the ones kind of taken
on water sunlight fox they definitely
have the biggest amount of I suppose
pressure because everyone is expecting
them to win just became one of the
greatest fighting game players on our
planet
I feel really really confident going
with a Sunday I I love to thinking whoa
in the hole
[Applause]
going into final combat 2021 name was on
everyone's lips ninja killer ninja
killers journey as a player is very
relatable and I think is partly why he's
so popular with the know the viewers and
the fans of the game is it's something
that anyone could have been very done
after just a year of playing at real
offline tournaments he was one of the
best players in the world
with the third seed going into the most
important tournament of the year ninja
killer was good really good actually
but there was just one problem he was
too young to travel to tournaments
unfortunately I couldn't compete you
know since I was still in school so
didn't have the funds to travel and
whatnot with him being in high school
initially we wanted him to focus on
school that was first and foremost it
was after I graduated didn't have a
chance to start you know competing and
traveling more to these events ninja
killer got his start grinding online
matches in the Mortal Kombat 10 but when
injustice 2 came out he didn't switch
over MKX like when it was like kind of
dead cuz people day was still playing
injustice too and I was one of those MKX
necro so that's not me my name as the
years went on he became known as this
mythical figure on a line and everyone
wanted to test their skills against him
ok lady was coming out during that time
there was telling me to start competing
for that game or in the fighting game
world we see it every every day right
where people that they only playoff
online and they never go offline it was
really nerve-wracking you know jumping
from online to like going offline like
it's the big gap don't get me wrong late
someone's known for online and there is
a certain part of the community I'll be
like yeah what was that really you know
as much of a big deal as as it's made
out to be he's he was playing the best
character in the game he was he never
stopped playing and everyone else
stopped playing and it's online he he
wouldn't do that offline that was a big
one knew he wouldn't do this offline and
he wouldn't do it against these pros I
would love to see ninja killer try while
we were all playing the game but he's
just playing a game that we're not
playing anymore and that's why he looks
so good
I got to prove them wrong I got to prove
all of them wrong late I got to prove
everyone who doubted me wrong you know
ninja Killa didn't start his journey
alone though he had something many
competitors but only wish they had the
unquestioning support of his family they
believed you know if if they show up
how you know like the confidence to win
more event you know since I got support
from my family or so yeah they just had
to coach me you know trying to give me
some support I was kind of surprised my
wife and I and how many kids would come
up to us and kind of congratulate us for
being apart and traveling with our kids
to these events I feel like it's always
good to have support from your family
you know you always want to have someone
that's there for your bag you know to
cheer you on you know it's just good to
have ninja Killa was an easy tournament
favorite heading into the world finals
but one player posed a threat to
everything he built up over his rookie
year Sonic's on this and the last breath
there's only one hit the down one gets
squeezed out and it's gonna be Sonic box
once again winning another Pro
competition sonic Fox they definitely
have the biggest amount of I suppose
pressure because everyone is expecting
them to win because they're the favorite
I love watching sonic play because they
happen to be incredibly good and that's
what we all aspire to be for seven years
they dominated injustice and Mortal
Kombat and they were the first seed
going in the final combat and Sonic had
an ace up their sleeve they were the
only player who was ready to bet it all
on Joker a brand new character who was
legal for final combat why take the risk
because Joker was perfectly designed to
fit sonic Fox's play style sonic Fox
playing Joker I think is an absolute
match made in character heaven I finally
feel like a nurse made a character where
I get to really really show of how
creative my craziness can be while also
showing off that creative side of me and
how crazy Joker is because I love like
don't guys with my favorite villain ever
exist period
it's everything that sonic Fox does well
it's splitsies it's pressure it's the
set ups it's the whole thing while being
this character that is you know funky
and kind of shows off while playing like
that's the animated style of the
character I just think it fits
sonic rocks perfectly and you have to be
thinking so many steps ahead it requires
a incredibly intelligent and smart
player to be able to recognize that and
make it work competitively and that's
why I think Joker is such a perfect fit
this weekend the fact that they created
this cool character with all these
setups that I can just sit there for
hours and hours and hours on end to most
lap feels so much fun when Sonic is
laughing that's that's when their most
lethal when when they're under giggle in
having a good time no chance now I get
to show off people like like how Cory
that's good
welcome ladies and gentlemen to final
combat 2020 we're at Park West in
Chicago Illinois where 16 are the best
players from around the world are ready
to fight in a best-of-five double
elimination tournament I feel really
really confident going into Sunday I
love to think ignore the whole thing
yeah I think I might do well I've been
practicing I've been grinding with the
oxygen all doing so I'm pretty confident
with the stage set both sonic Fox and
ninja killer got to work sonic Fox was
feeling extremely confident and despite
a pretty close game with their round 1
opponents tabs decided to play with
their food a little and disrespected and
a bash to the head I sought solace and
takes game number see if sonic fosters
trying to send a message to every
competitor in here that it doesn't
matter if I'm down to one I will come
back and mercy you got a flawless bought
that triple pointed okay last breaths
shot to the face dreams were crushed
with a Foley
as staff is sent into losers valiant
effort and beautiful display by golden
players I think that's that's a very
sonic fox thing to do is to find the way
to express themselves while also kind of
being a jerk about it you know after
that it was smooth sailing for sonic
locks straight to the winners finals
remember this outtake there's no camera
there's no shades crushing blow
so what projectiles that jump kick hurts
all time and just right there combat
loss meanwhile on the other side of the
bracket ninja killer was having a much
harder time despite easily dispatching
his round one opponent conquer he had a
mountain to climb to make it to the
winners finals for his faded showdown
with Sonic Fox first tweety pushed him
to his limits making this old one
[Applause]
oh good budget now he's just showing off
now sweetie this is a guessing game
gravel made one read away save him this
time we were due to again number five
once again give it a break throw it is
that completely calculated up seven
point three remaining for joining the
approach and then dragon long considered
the second best player in the world
right behind sonic Fox showed ninja
killer that he wasn't gonna give up his
spot at the top so easily dragons not
gonna go for the breakaway try to save
the par attend to your last lifeline but
that one hurts that one hurts so good
ninja killin out to zero up if he gets
one clean confirmed this will be a 3-0
he tries he tries but remember fatal
blow armor does not work the same way
used to this is scary now ninja killer
one clean opening and this is game over
and as long as you kill her there's
going to be chip territory that last
breath might save him one opportunity
and there's the boss spent Double Dragon
brings it back to two twos he's fishing
for it oh you know which ninja killer
bite the fatal blow as dragon goes down
to the loser's bracket it is gonna be
ninja killer versus
come back he walked his place in the
winners finals against sonic Fox it
wasn't the end of the tournament just
yet but ninja Killa was up against the
best player in the world at the most
important tournament of the year I'm not
really nervous about playing Sonic again
like you know he's kind of one of those
players like I kind of practice with
like he knows how I play and I know how
he plays so you know it goes back and
forth between those building his
playstyle is very similar to mine I
think alike and we play alike but like I
understand how to beat a player like
myself so I went around the measures to
make sure I America had stopped playing
like myself he's one of the only players
in the world that you can say absolutely
could not only beat Sonic Fox
but if he's having a good day destroy
Sonic Fox oh I like to think I'm gonna
like take him out I've heard encounter
him in tournament I was difficult
destroy him in this tournament
I'm really really grinding and really
really like studying these habits and
everything so I feel really really
confident at beating him but what the
people watching at home didn't know is
that Sonic Fox and ninja killer had
already played each other that weekend
these two actually played in a money
match where ninja Killa won not only one
set but after he won his money match
sonic fox was very salty and said no run
it back double or nothing
ninja kala won that and double this bet
yeah he beat me like eight to reckon he
liked the story me but I was just like I
know exactly what I'm doing wrong here I
got to your door a ninja killer had a
chance to prove that even gods can bleed
I can either one taking mini risk all
right now that's because it was on
cooldown when he grabbed you know even
though it came back during the animation
still it'll pop it and water come up
between the forward to it
Oh liver late low and whether it's
amplified or whether there was gonna be
crushing blow no longer matters right
though micro ducky check now sand
getting those they called each other out
for it and you saw Joker not able to get
the kind of shadow catch punish cap
board one right into it what a cancel in
sauna quacks sixth row what about you
but that's not fire out there I and
ducking under and down oh there was no
break away nevermind wasn't even an
option sonic Fox in there now it's match
point still in the approach and Hawks is
back ninja kill up all the way to corner
there's a lot of respect and now a
double fatal blow territory oh he doing
something there and through the
breakaway gets the flying kick ninja
stays alive
these two are playing some amazing
Mortal Kombat right now this is fast of
quick reads quick reactions
it's not boy death help remaining and
are we gonna go to a game five just
another here we go gonna be here check
it on - here we go to a final here all
of a sudden from the decks of what
looked like the beasts words sonic Fox's
victory now has match point of his own
everybody in here is standing right now
in anticipation of what's about to
happen
breaks the throat the grand finals here
at final combat 2020 Nanji Killa had
done it he triumphed over the best
player Mortal Kombat had ever seen at
the biggest tournament of the year but
sonic wasn't going down without a fight
sonic was knocked down to the loser's
bracket where they had to face off
against dragon still hungry to prove his
mettle but sonic fox was a hungrier they
wanted a rematch against ninja Killa and
they dominated a dragon that's quite a
bit up in the second guys there wasn't
enough by beating dragon sonic Fox was
back in the grand finals up against
ninja killer it all came down to this
ninja killer was out to prove the
doubters wrong that his skills were real
that he wouldn't crumble under the
pressure he'd already beaten the best
player in the world of ones that day now
he had to prove that he could do it
again like I made it to the finale the
guy would prove the point you know but
it would be amazing if I can take this
finale I feel really really confident at
beating him with the beef between these
two here we go grand finals everybody
here's the Hat and immediately into the
confirm 370 and by the way the Carson
wool on the follow-through continue so
as the result sonic Parks saves the
fatal blow and also a suppression blow
in the three set point I wasn't gonna
say a word one set to determine the
greatest Mortal Kombat player on this
planet oh here we go now for the first
time sonic Fox is winning this
tournament appoint oh that was the
mix-up for sure no it was I'm starting
to get to be the cancel on the fatal
blow we have ourselves a match one set
of peace between the two one game
between the two this is the grand finals
a final combat everybody I got one
loaded I'll take away nah man hold up do
you guys believe in magic here oh it's
not even magical one more year or the
forward grab is gonna be enough is it
another compact very just like that just
like a nice eat eat the infamous kumbhak
match of the year another massive
comeback for Sonic
that one too is a double - out - great
collinear by Sonic congratulations to
Sonic for once again being your world
champion with the Joker the match was
over ninja killer just sat there stunned
his family was always ready to support
him and they weren't the only ones
ninja killem may not have won but with
barely a year of tournament experience
under his belt he went toe to toe with
some of the best players in the world
and proved that he deserves to be
counted among their ranks straight up I
think he's a genius and I think he's a
prodigy definitely don't think he was
ready for a tournament as of this
caliber in terms of pressure that was
put on him but I do know he's gonna come
back next year way way harder but in
terms of the skill set in neutral
control and just fighting game knowledge
it's like looking at my sis like maybe
myself in the past it's like looking
like like a myself in the past but like
10 times better
that's grace he's at I'm like damn I
wish I was this nasty when I was 19 so
he's a phenomenal player and I hope to
play more games to be honest
you
you